[Musique]
[Rires]
on sait pas quand c'est le direct
on est de retour sur télémator direct
avec Élie Semoun Emmanuel Macron est
arrivé hier à Washington pour une visite
d'État de 4 jours l'image que nous avons
retenu c'est juste avant que l'avion
atterrit c'est une allégorie de la
politique voilà ceci est une allégorie
de la politique un escalier qui monte et
qui débouche sur du vide quelle est la
marge de manœuvre là pour Emmanuel
Macron auprès de Joe Biden Joe Biden va
l'écouter d'une oreille polie mais ça
servira pas à grand chose alors je ne
sais pas ma femme Biden est très poli il
met la main il met la main facilement la
main aux fesses des gens il est très
dangereux pour le contact il est dans le
contact
on prend la ligne de ces mois là on voit
leurs points forts c'est soit c'est la
hauteur soit c'est la longueur on la
coupe avec dans les femelles et plus le
croisement est réussi plus il y a des
mères là donc le but les revendre à de
riches familles sénégalaises pour
l'élevage ou la consommation les plus
exceptionnels participent à des concours
de beauté comme Joe Biden ce mal de 180
kg alors un bronze sujet étonnant un
sujet étonnant comme vous dites Sophie
effectivement puisque vous avez cette
jeune femme allongée sur le ventre vous
voyez qu'elle tient une grappe de raisin
et puis vous avez cette chèvre qui est
en train de lui lécher l'oreille ce qui
est un petit peu un petit peu surprenant
vous avez vu quand il est propre et
comme on offre chez nous
pour acquérir Joe Biden comptez au moins
10.000 euros la plupart des Sénégalais
comme Moussa n'ont pas les moyens mais
ne se lasse pas du spectacle pour
accueillir la plus grande des
compétitions de football le
Qatar a défoncé sans compter plus de 200
milliards d'euros depuis 2010
en comparaison en 98 la France a
déboursé l'équivalent d'un virgule 3
milliards d'euros l'Afrique du Sud près
de 4 milliards en 2010 puis 11,6
milliards pour le Brésil presque autant
que la Russie il y a 4 ans au reste de
l'actualité cette information de premier
apporte évidemment
il pourquoi la chronique est pas
terminée ça c'est vraiment une Maniche
et TF1 il lance des pubs alors que les
choses ne sont pas terminées c'est pas
possible c'est le plus grand vol de
l'histoire
TF1 a arrêté le match mais c'est fou
et sur TF1 il y a des pub
non mais c'est fou c'est le multivers là
sur TF1 le match s'est arrêté et là ça
continue sur BeIn Sport c'est improbable
est-ce qu'il fait réagir au standard ce
matin c'est Sandrine Rousseau qui est
estimait que les Bleus étaient je cite
des pleutres car il n'était pas engagé
en faveur de la cause LGBT au Qatar oui
c'est une sortie assez directe assez
musclé qui a stupéfait d'ailleurs Émilie
de Montélimar qui nous dit eh ben dis
donc à la nupesse il y a pas que Adrien
katnas qui n'y va pas demain morte André
une Rousseau demande finalement à
l'équipe de France d'avoir le courage
qu'elle n'a pas elle-même pourquoi
Sandrine Rousseau n'est pas parti à Doha
manifester avec les couleurs LGBT elle
elle reste dans un studio de radio et
qui passe tous les jours dans les études
sur place allez-y soyez courageux pour
nous dénoncer ce qu'on aimerait bien
dénoncer c'est quand même
TF1 a dû faire un communiqué il faut me
faire que des communiqués en ce moment
qu'elle a reçu
les spectateurs après la remise en jeu
des Tunisiens
et que l'arbitre a sifflé la fin du
match nous avons comme pour tous les
matchs rendu l'antenne pour laisser la
place au mag ça sert à rien le bac
retransmettez le match et tout ce qu'on
vous demande pendant ce laps de temps un
arbitrage vidéo a été demandé et le but
tricolore refusé cette séquence a fait
l'ouverture du mag nous sommes vraiment
désolé pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu vivre
ce moment en direct c'est bien que
l'équipe de France évolue vers la phase
élimination directe avec un peu moins de
confiance et pour montrer que il faut se
remettre en question ok parole de
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur fouetter ça fait
du bien
[Rires]
Saint-Denis que trépasse si je faiblis
[Musique]
que Patrick Balkany
[Rires]
le covid fait son retour celui des
gestes barrières pas vraiment le port du
masque par exemple les recommandé par le
gouvernement mais difficile de faire
renouer les Français avec ses habitudes
c'est obligatoire oui mais sinon non une
simple recommandation ça suffit pas non
le fait de juste recommander il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont pas le faire
mais moi je le fais pas alors que je
devrais le faire vu les contradictions
qu'il y a eu en fait
ça va deux minutes les conneries on peut
remercier pour parents Babette
il va falloir que vous me remplaciez au
pied
vous nous l'avez mis c'est la fin c'est
les derniers instants je suis directrice
de pompes funèbres mesdames et messieurs
une directrice de pompes funèbre et
parmi nous
une dernière image elle nous vient de
l'Assemblée tu nous guette aujourd'hui
[Musique]